joining me now is Lisa Booth Fox News
contributor and Evita Duffy Alfonso a
staff writer at the Federalist uh Lisa
feminism today seems to be about
commodifying women I thought we were
supposed to get away from that
well I think the intention is
hopelessness
I think that's what the left wants for
for the younger Generations I think they
want a generation of hopeless women who
are are not happy in their lives not
fulfilled and that's why they're trying
to remove these anchors from our lives
like Faith like family like
relationships that give us purpose
because empty vessels are more easily
controllable and it's working I mean if
you look at some of the studies I think
CDC was out with a study not too long
ago where almost 57 percent of high
school girls feel persistent feeling of
sadness or hopelessness one in three
high school girls have seriously
considered suicide and and I think
that's with intention is to drive people
to that hopeless feeling in life uh and
it's working and it's sad
Evita you're young you look just like
your mom
and you're married I think right you're
married at a young age yes
well you you defy you defy in many ways
the prevalent thought in your generation
because there are a lot of young people
who are being told that you know
marriage is just again it's a prison
it's outdated you do what you want to do
don't worry about the old traditions in
the old ways especially women and you
say
yeah I mean that's that's exactly right
I was in college not too long ago I saw
the way that hookup culture really hurt
women I know that the left is telling
women that that in order to be happy in
order to have value you have to forego
marriage you have to focus more on your
career than your love life and the
reality is that's just not true that's
not true um for for your soul that's not
true biologically women
um and and men really want to want to be
happy need to be together right and and
there's so much hatred between the Sexes
that that the the left is stoking
um and I'll say this if you want to be
happy in life do the opposite of
everything that the left is telling
young women to do that's that's really
the answer to all of our problems and
this is really feminism radical feminism
it's really Under the Umbrella of
neo-marxism and what they want to do is
is not Empower women or help women they
hurt women right I mean they destroy
women sports they they hurt them uh
socially uh internally you see that
liberal women are not happy
um what they're doing is they're trying
to destroy everything that's good and
beautiful in the world starting with
femininity and they yeah and they turn
when they say beauty it's something that
none of us recognize as Beauty not on
the inside and not on the outside now a
recent piece uh Lisa highlighted this
new phenomenon I guess in the dating
world when it comes to men noting that
more than six and ten men ages 18 to 29
are now single one man says a lot of us
are checking out we're just tired of
being told that we don't measure up
either physically or financially
Lisa wow that's depressing
well we've created this really confusing
landscape for for dating you know I I I
will disagree I do think there's this
push on the right right now to tell
everyone that you need to be married in
your 20s and I don't agree with that in
the sense of I think I believe in God
and I think God's timing is right uh he
has a different path for each of us in
life so and that's going to look
different for for each person you know I
know for myself you know I'm 38 I
haven't been married yet I don't think I
was ready to be married when I was
younger you know and then I'm very
stubborn I think God needed like a
little more time with me to mold me beta
was really smart Aveda had it together
she was lucky but you know I needed like
a little bit more time Laura and then
now that I'm ready I think my guys just
may be taking the scenic route to get
here but you know I think each of us
have a different path in life so I don't
think we should have a narrow uh minded
approach to it and if that's getting
married in your 20s that's beautiful if
it's getting married at a later Point
that's also beautiful uh well the good
thing is you both are beautiful and I
know we're going to keep talking about
these topics because I'm told everybody
wants to talk about these topics and I
think they're really interesting
Lisa and Aveda thanks so much tonight
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else